before the president talked about
impeachment this morning members of
Congress from both parties said it's too
early to think about it but Senate
Democrats are using Cohen's plea-bargain
to try to delay the confirmation
hearings for the president's Supreme
Court nominee judge Brett Kavanaugh
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning for political
reasons Democrats are steering clear of
that word impeachment but not steering
clear of the word delay when it comes to
the president's Supreme Court nominee in
fact one Democrat mazie Hirono of Hawaii
was scheduled to sit down with Cavanaugh
today but she cancelled saying now is
not the time to extend that courtesy to
a president who is living under a legal
cloud what cloud are you talking about
Republicans say the president's legal
woes have nothing to do with his Supreme
Court pick I just don't get the
connection but Democrats are looking for
any way to slow things down this
nomination is now tainted we should be
withholding this decision on a Supreme
Court nominee until the air is cleared
and we know exactly where we stand comes
to this president and his culpability
for all their talk of culpability there
is one term Democrats shied away from
Wednesday do you think that this rises
to the level of impeachment I think we
want answers from the investigation I
think impeachment talk is something that
is not something that we should be
engaging in right now Democratic leaders
from Pelosi on down insists that
impeachment is not a priority they're
weary of whipping up the GOP base with
two and a half months to go before the
midterm elections
it's a Watergate moment Connecticut's
Richard Blumenthal was the only Senate
Democrat willing to go there every
single remedy including indictment of
the president should be on the table the
president can be indicted I don't think
he can be indicted well sitting in
office Utah Republican Orrin Hatch voted
to impeach President Bill Clinton in
1999 after he lied under oath to cover
up an affair has any senator who
supported impeaching President Clinton
need to think seriously about
in future president Truong well not at
this point but I mean we have to take
these matters very seriously he was one
of just a handful of Republicans to say
that Michael Cohen's plea deal poses
potentially a serious problem for the
president
others downplayed the charges or said
that they're waiting for more
information but a top GOP aide told me
that behind the scenes Senate
Republicans are more uncomfortable now
than they have ever been with some of
the president's practices before he took
office and while in the Oval Office
Norah really interesting to hear all
those voices Nancy thank you so much